[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello listening
friends would you like to hear some
amazing facts people often have
misconceptions about which animals are
truly dangerous for example lions are
called the king of the beasts but
statistically they're not the most
deadly about 250 people a year die from
lion attacks surprisingly even though
they're vegetarians the World Health
Organization says hippos and elephants
each kill about 500 people a year
globally they're about 40 bear attacks
every year but only four of them result
in death
by contrast every year approximately a
thousand people are killed by crocodiles
statistically dogs are more deadly than
crocodiles about thirty-five thousand
people a year die in dog attacks yes
these are your everyday domestic dogs
that turn dishes in case you're afraid
of getting in the ocean a person's
chance of getting killed by a shark is
less than 1 in 264 million only 6 deaths
per year globally related to sharks on
the other hand venomous snakes do a
pretty good job living up to their
deadly reputation killing up to 100,000
people a year mostly through encounters
with Cobras Vipers or crates sadly most
of these deaths could be prevented with
better access to anti-venom
you know the Bible talks about a special
serpent anti-venom that still works
today
stay where those friends we're going to
learn more on this edition of Bible
answers live you're listening to Bible
answers live accurate and practical
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and if you've got a Bible
question this is the program we
encourage you to give us a call the
number is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven calling now good chance
you're gonna get your question on
tonight's broadcast 800 God says that's
800 for six three seven two nine seven
we do have some lines open and we'd love
to study the word with you not only can
you be listening on the radio if you
want you could be watching via Facebook
we are broadcasting on the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page as well as the
amazing facts Facebook page and after
you tune in you can send a text your
friends and tell them to join in if they
have a Bible question my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening friends and pastor Doug let's
start the program with prayer dear
father we thank you the gray/blue spend
a few moments opening up your word and
studying together and Lord we ask for
your guidance and your blessing be with
us here in the studio and be with those
who are listening and those who call in
Lord pray that you'd lead us into
clearer understanding of Bible truth in
Jesus name Amen amen
Oh pastor Doug in your opening fact he
just confirmed what I believe my whole
life and that is stay away from snakes
they're not good for you I teach pastor
Ross a little bit because you know
everyone's got their their phobias and
he doesn't like snakes one bit
matter of fact we did a program with
kids this last year in Michigan and they
brought in as an illustration it looked
like it was a 10 foot Python big ol
heavy snake and that's runner by Q he
was trying to bite me I had a I had him
behind the neck and he was using all his
strength to swing around and keepers
were said no he's just yawning I don't
know he's trying to swallow me but I
noticed that you're at the other end of
the bill
I'm from Africa and it's like the
don't play around with highly dangerous
they teach you at an early age that it
even looks like a snake
get away get away that's right well you
know the Bible talks about snakes and
right there in the beginning in Genesis
we know that the devil used the serpent
as a medium and so from that point all
the way through revelation where you
read in revelation 12 verse 9 that Satan
is identified as that serpent of old the
devil and Satan that old dragon and you
know Jesus says that you can read mark
16 and when we're filled with the spirit
he says you will take up serpents it
doesn't mean we're going around taking
up snakes it means we're gonna be able
to take on the devil and it says you'll
tread on the serpent and the young lion
speaking of two symbols of the devil you
find in Psalms it talks about their so
with that in mind Jesus makes everyone
knows John 3:16 which says of course for
God so loved the world he gave His only
begotten Son that whosoever believeth in
him should not perish but have
everlasting life but many people are
unaware that that's almost repeated word
for word in John 3 verse 14 and 15
Christ said as Moses lifted up the
serpent in the wilderness even so must
the Son of Man be lifted up that
whosoever believes in Him should not
perish but have everlasting life so
Christ points back to this experience in
the Book of Numbers where a plague of
serpents went through the people the
camp of Israel deadly serpents and many
people were bitten and were dying and
God told Moses to make a bronze Serpent
and to lift it up on a pole like a
shepherd staff and whoever looked at
that in faith would be healed of the
venom Christ said as Moses did that so
the Son of Man Jesus would be lifted up
on the cross of course that whoever
looks in faith we are healed from the
venom of the devil from the venom the
power of sin
you know the venom of many serpents I
forget which snake it is they call it a
two-stepper because they say when you're
bit you got about two steps
before you die maybe an exaggeration but
some serpents are extremely venomous and
if you've been bitten by the serpent the
devil and if you sin the penalty for sin
is death the only antidote is the blood
of Jesus believing in the cross of
Calvary and we have a book that I think
will encourage and inspire you and how
you can get that cure we're gonna offer
for free tonight the book is called the
Savior and the serpent and as mentioned
we'll send it to anyone who calls an ass
this is our free off offer tonight our
free gift all you'll need to do is call
the number eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven that is the
resource phone line after the book
called the Savior and the serpent that
number Yanni's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and if you
have a Bible question our phone line
here to the studio is eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven it's 800
four 63 72 ninety seven can you go to
the phone lines we have our first call
it's Charles listening in Florida
Charles II on Bible answers life hey
pastor dog pastor Ross I had a question
on the in the book of Revelation chapter
18 verse 8 where it talks about the
plague now is now is that the particular
place that is supposed to take all take
place in one day or that or does that
mean it's like it's supposed to be old
like over a period of time like days or
weeks or well the great question and let
me read this for our friends it's
talking about the plagues that fall on
Babylon and it says there for her
plagues Babylon is called a harlot so
it's using the feminine language here
therefore her plagues will come in a day
death and mourning and famine and she
will be utterly burned with fire for
strong as the Lord who judges her in
Bible prophecy a day typically
represents a year and you find a number
of prophecies in both Revelation Daniel
where they use there's different dates
that are given times and most Bible
scholars this is not a denominational
thing most Bible scholars most
Protestant scholars understand the day
for the year principle when they're
studying the prophecies of daniel and
revelation
so when it says all her plagues will
come in a day that really means in
within one year it's all gonna happen
and it's speaking of the seven plagues
that you read about earlier in chapters
about fifteen and sixteen and then
you'll notice just to add to that a
little bit in verse 10 of the same
chapter revelation 18 it talks about her
judgment coming in one hour so her
plagues fall within a period of about a
year but then it specifically talks
about a judgment that comes upon a rod
at the end which is final destruction it
says it comes with one hour typically an
hour in Bible prophecies about 14 days
so we also have a reference to half an
hour in Revelation chapter eight about
seven days so there's some interesting
time periods that we have mentioned in
this chapter yeah matter of fact I could
be wrong but I think three times in
chapter 18 it says one hour and it's
describing different things in one hour
it's like falling politically one hour
it's falling economically and forget
what the third one is yeah if you're
looking for a 17-4 as in one hour such
great riches come to nothing so it seems
like it's describing that within a
year's time when the seven plagues are
falling Babylon which is the seed of the
beast it's imploding and in you know
though it may have taken 2,000 years to
build itself falls very quickly by
comparison and we have a lesson on okay
the the woman the beast and the dragon
talks about Babylon we'll be happy to
send that to anyone who wants to learn
more about the subject actually are you
thinking of the study guide called the
other woman which is either one who
Babylon we get the Joe Cruz book called
the beast the dragon and the woman okay
and then we've got the study guide so we
could sing you either one talking about
babbling and the one the study guides
called the other woman or you can ask
for the book called the beast the dragon
and the woman and the number to call for
that is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and again just ask
for one of those office dealing with the
subject of Babel and in Bible prophecy
thank you for your call Charles we got
Chris listening in Florida Chris welcome
to the program yes thank you Pastor good
evening
evening I just have a question from
second Timothy and
some second Timothy 2:20 21 can you read
that for me please sure and I'll be
happy to and Paul is writing here but in
a great house they're not only vessels
of gold and silver but also of wood and
clay some for honor some for dishonor
but in a great house I'm sorry but
therefore if anyone cleanses himself
from the latter he will be a vessel of
Honor sanctified and useful for the
master prepared for every good work
are you wondering what that means or
what are these vessels I just need a
little help with understanding it you
know the Bible tells us that God is the
Potter and we are the clay in fact I
think you can also read in Romans
chapter 9 it says does not the Potter
have power over the clay to make from
one lump a vessel for honor and another
vessel for dishonor and a vessel is it
holds something and we are supposed to
be vessels with God's Spirit there's a
number of parables and stories about
vessels in the Bible and they're often
analogies of people and Bible talks
about these vessels filled with oil in
2nd Kings chapter 4 this woman has these
empty vessels and they're miraculously
filled with oil what oils a type of the
Holy Spirit we're to all be filled with
God's Spirit so Paula st. in the church
you know you've got all kinds of
different gifts different people have
different gifts summer gold and silver
summer wood and clay some have more
honorable positions some arm is more
dishonorable Paul also talking about
spiritual gifts in is at 1st Corinthians
14 he said we got honorable parts of the
body
we've got dishonorable parts of the body
some are covered up so you've got the
head the nose the eyes and you got the
toes and if you could vote and say I'd
rather be a toe not too many people
would ask for that but it's a very
important part of the body so Paul is
using similar analogy here talking about
the vessels does that make sense Chris
hey thank you so much we appreciate your
call and we do have I've got an article
online
that talks about the the church body and
these vessels and matter of fact we have
a lesson called jar of oil its
historical lesson that talks about the
vessels being full of oil and we'll be
happy to send that to you Chris so
anyone wanting to learn more the number
is 883 five six seven four seven you can
ask for one of the offers you're not
always hand out but it's a great
resource called the jar of oil it's one
of our study guide historical lessons
and we'll be able to send it to anyone
who calls and asks next caller that we
have is Mike and is listening in
Missouri Mike welcome to the program
[Music]
I saw pitcher Doug Bair on his 50th
birthday do a back flip on television
well I hope you taped it because you
won't see it again yeah I I think I've
gotten the victory over there and you
know if if someone were to offer you
know 1 million dollar donation for the
ministry I might be able to do one more
if I had a big pillow under me but yeah
do you have a question for us Mike yes I
do I heard it was a swim for the
patriarchs like Abraham to observed the
weekly Sabbath because Adamson
interrupted the Sabbath established it
Eden you know there's nothing in the
Bible that says that in fact pastor Ross
might help me find it where it says that
Abraham kept my statutes my judgments
and my Commandments that's Genesis it
might be 25 and trying to remember but
yeah Abraham kept the commandments of
God and his laws and his judgments and
his statutes and so I'm sure the Sabbath
was part of that they it wasn't a sin
and even by the time you get to Exodus
chapter 3 the children Israel we're
keeping the Sabbath before they ever got
to Mount Sinai the verse you're
referring to is Genesis chapter 26 verse
5 where it says that Abraham obeyed my
voice kept my charge my commandments my
statutes and my laws that would
certainly include the Sabbath
commandment that starts in Genesis
chapter 2 and as I mentioned that in
Exodus
sixteen God called the Sabbath a law and
asked the children of Israel how long
will you refuse to keep my Commandments
he had not given the Ten Commandments
yet that's chapter 19 so there's nothing
that would make us think that the
continuity of one of the Ten
Commandments was broken for a period of
time but there's all kinds of
interesting theories people have out
there but I don't see any scripture you
know we got a lesson dealing with this
it's called written in stone and we'll
be happy to send it to you Mike or
anyone wanting to learn more about what
does the Bible say about the Ten
Commandments just call and ask for the
study guide called written in stone and
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven and of course we'll send it out to
anyone who calls and asks we've got
their Carlos listening from New Jersey
Carlos welcome to the program hi I would
like to first say I love you guys
I appreciate amazing facts it's a
blessing in my home and I have my
question I have seen a YouTube video by
amazing discoveries Walter V and it's
called the Battle of the Bibles and
within that video he presents all of the
Bible translations have missing passages
except for the King James Version so my
question is that being that being said
should the those versions be used for
ministry purposes like on video
presentations and stuff of that nature
all right well now Pastor Ross and
Walter fighter both from South Africa I
love you
I don't you want to answer this but we
their friends actually and we have great
respect for our God but I might
respectfully disagree that
that it's wrong or unethical to use any
other translation the King James is a
masterpiece but it is certainly it's not
flawless as a translation there are
places that the language in the King
James is hard to understand in some
cases it's miss punctuated I did a video
this week called baptism for the dead
where I have to explain that some of the
verse there in 1st Corinthians 15 I
think it's verse 29 the punctuation is
wrong in the King James Version and
leaving people yes I saw that video
today actually yeah so I mean the King
James was a masterpiece it's there's no
document that's done more to shape the
English language in the King James and
and I believe God was deeply behind that
translation but I can't think you got to
be careful of saying that every other
translation is automatically suspect
there are strengths to some of the other
translations that John yeah you know it
is a fact that there are different
manuscripts that are used in the
translation into English some of these
original manuscripts that were used
missed or did not have some verses that
you find in the Textus Receptus so there
are about 16 verses if I'm not mistaken
that you won't find in in more modern
translations which you would find in the
King James of the New King James it's
not necessarily that the translators
would purposely leaving that out but the
manuscripts they were using to translate
where those verses were missing so
that's why it'll jump from one verse to
you know maybe even skip it entire verse
and then go to the next one so I think
one thing to remember that when studying
the Bible just remember that the Bible
wasn't written in English or in Spanish
but it was written in Hebrew a little
bit of Aramaic and of course Greek and I
like to compare driving translations and
with the modern ability to just click
with your mouse on your various Bible
software you can see where that word was
used and how it was translated so yeah I
like passage I said there's some things
that are actually translated better more
accurate to the original language with a
different translation in the King James
but there are things translating the
King James and New King James there are
better than
the other translations like when you
read revelation and the the King James
translators said that the Satan's cast
into the bottomless pit well as a very
colorful creative term but I mean what
is the Balinese at a black hole in space
well that same word the same translators
decided to translate that word deep in
Luke chapter 8 says the devil said do
not cast us into the deep the same word
is abuso same word so yeah everyone
wants to know what is this bottomless
pit and I think they got near the end of
the Bible they got creative so it's not
the best translation it means the
nothingness so there are places that
even the King James Version maybe has
some things could be done better they
were humans that did the translation the
Word of God is perfect yeah yeah and you
know we do have a little book carlos
will be happy to st. you it's called the
ultimate resource and it's all about the
bible talk about how we got the Bible
and even touches a little bit on
translations and we'll be happy to send
that to anyone who calls and ask again
the book is called the ultimate resource
and the number to call for that is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and again just ask for the book
called the ultimate resource 808 three
five six seven four seven next caller
that we have is Emanuel listening from
Africa Emanuel welcome to the program
and then at 12 under God not murder and
then I feel that came murdered his
brother Hobart yes so when I'm acting
compassion the murder and killing when
to get good walk how we're going to get
good murders and they're doing it all
right legal measures of the idea of the
Goodman I understand now there's a good
question so it says in the ten
commandments you shall not murder and of
course God told Cain that sin lies at
your door and he murdered his brother
and murder is a sin murder is a
different from killing yes there are
soldiers that go to battle and in the
process of defending their country or
fighting for liberty whether they may be
asked to kill and I that would not be
defined as murder murder is technically
the unlawful taking of innocent life and
if a policeman has to shoot some violent
criminal to save people's life you don't
call that murder technically whenever
you pull a weed from a garden you're
killing or if you swat a mosquito or
trap a mouse you're killing so the
commandments not just don't kill it
commandment is don't murder which is
different and matter of fact I think
it's in mark chapter 10 pastor oz for
Jesus in reciting the Ten Commandments a
he it's in a few of the Gospels he uses
the term thou shalt not murder
he doesn't say kill because that's
technically something a little more
accurate God can't say don't kill after
he drowns everyone in the flood no he
got you know God can't say don't kill
and then he he tells the the Israelites
they were exterminate their enemies the
Amalekites but murder is something
different it's the unlawful taking of
innocent life and the virtue referring
to is Matthew 19 verse 18 yeah Jesus
says don't murder there hey thank you
Emmanuel it's always good to hear from
Africa and good morning to you and of
course we have our study guide on the
Ten Commandments written in stone you
mentioned earlier that can be downloaded
mm-hmm for free you can download by just
simply going to the amazing facts
website next caller that we have is
Julie Oh listening in Washington State
program oh you like doing good how are
you doing good man thank you for what
I'm sorry Michael and your question in
yeah my question is pretty similar
mother
just the gaia start okay a little while
ago yeah my question is how about the
numbers 15 from 32 mm-hmm
verse 32 to 36 are when men when a guy
was speaking up sticks and was counsel
so I what I understand more the death
penalty on doing something on the towel
you know yeah when in the children of
Israel going through the wilderness
there is a man that you know ignored
God's commandment not to gather wood for
a fire on Sabbath they were to do that
ahead of time
and matter of fact he said they weren't
to Kindle a fire on Sabbath that that
didn't mean they couldn't have a fire
but the kindling of a fire was a lot of
work and so they were to get their fires
going in advance and have the wood ready
so they could rest well this guy just
totally ignored the commandments of God
and God's right in their presence they
could see his pillar of cloud and they
said to Moses what do we do and this man
was guilty of what you would call a
high-handed sin and Moses said that he
should be executed now if that sounds
serious you could go to Acts chapter 5
in the New Testament
Ananias and Sapphira they died for lying
and you know God judged them for just
telling a lie
so when a person is committing a
high-handed sin in the presence of God
sometimes the Lord dealt with that very
severely now we don't do that you know
where God's not telling the church to
execute people who lie and break the
Sabbath yeah yeah be short on memory
soon but anyway
all right does that help a little bit
yeah yeah come to my mind when I
sometimes I build my fire on the side
you know that I'm like that you'll be
killed yeah well yeah we have a fire on
it you know if you if you're cold and
there's nothing you can do I think God
he'll show mercy in our home and we heat
our house with firewood I put a log on
the fire floor I came over here but on
Friday I have the fire built or the
other thing I do if I know I'm coming
home after Sabbath I've got the the wood
in the fire I've got the paper all ready
to light I got the kindling under the
wood I just have to put a match to it
and so it's all ready to go
so the idea of the Sabbath is again all
the work out of the way ahead of time if
you can and I think when Jesus or God
specifically told Israel not to Kindle a
fire on the Sabbath during their
wilderness wanderings you can imagine
having to go out and find wood in the
wilderness it was a big task and you
have that many people trying to make
fires you just imagine the amount of
work involved in trying to light a fire
or make a fire yeah and it was different
when they were settling the land of
promise yeah and it got a lot colder in
Jerusalem that it did probably in the
desert there Thank You Julio appreciate
your call another color that we have is
well I don't have time to take another
caller pastor Doug we have less than a
minute to go but maybe we could take
this opportunity just to let you know
the program it's not finished we'll be
coming back with more questions but if
you haven't seen the amazing facts
website it's probably a good place to go
and visit yeah just take a look at
amazing VAX dot o-r-g we've also got
some archives of bible questions and
matter of fact we're putting out a new
book pretty soon some of the most
popular bible questions that we've
received is going to hit the press so I
think shortly
don't go away friends we're coming back
we see you folks lined up a dab in woody
and Brioni and Anthony and Craig we're
gonna get your questions in just a
minute
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor
explores the most striking Bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history kingdoms in
time get your copy today available now
on DVD blu-ray or USB for more
information visit kingdoms in time.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 my name is Jean Ross and
we're gonna go to our next color we have
Deb listening in Minnesota
Deb walked with the program hi guys hi
um I kind of have a weird question but
I'm sure you've pretty much heard just
about everything by now we hear new ones
they don't when I was a young teen my
younger siblings and I were playing with
a Ouija board and I had asked like Who
am I gonna marry and the Ouija board
actually spelled out my husband's name
but I didn't meet my husband until I was
19 so I was wondering can Satan know
your future
well no Satan does not know I think the
details of people's future like that
because you'd have to be omniscient
to know that far in advance there's a
lot of prophecies that Satan makes that
are sort of generalizations sometimes
Satan is a very bright at guesstimating
providentially what might happen do you
mind my asking does your husband have a
really bizarre name or is it a fairly
common name yeah no it's not a common
name that's the thing I'm it spelled his
first name really quickly
and then the last name it had a little
trouble with because that's that's not a
very usual name so yeah that's not I
used to before I was a Christian as a
kid I used to play with a Ouija board -
and and we saw some things happen that
seemed like there was spiritual forces
involved
I don't think pastor Ross may want to
weigh in but personally I don't think
the devil knows that detail and the
devil knows what Bible prophecy says
about his future and the devil knows our
future if we're lost because he's going
to share our future for the lost you're
gonna end up in the lake of fire but I
don't think the devil has all the
details of our lives like God does he's
not all-knowing okay so you know I would
just write that up to coincidence
or there may be some way that you know
the devil he knew from cause-and-effect
who you were gonna meet I don't know now
I'm kind of delving into a world that I
just be guessing okay but the bible does
say god and god only knows the thoughts
of me men's hearts and there's another
couple of scriptures that talk about
god's ability to discern the future i he
said I'm the only one who can declare
from ancient times what will come to
pass
I think that's Isaiah so I don't believe
the devil has that power and yeah it is
kind of bizarre if you're hunter if your
husband's name was Bob which is the same
forward or backward and the devil guess
that well I got you know 50 friends
named Bob so it's not that much of a
miracle alright I hope that helps a
little bit Deb
by the way you want to hear something
really spooky my name is a Deb to it no
really it's a Douglas edward bachelor so
there you have it oh all right all right
thanks guys
yep next one of the we have is Kevin
listening all the way over in Australia
Kevin welcome to the program thank you
pasta hey you think you mind my asking
what part of Australia you're in I mean
cream Glen okay yeah we'll be in
Melbourne and Adelaide next week so a
little ways from you
oh yeah we'll be I'll see if I can make
some time to travel update to see yeah
all right yeah of the fire is gone out
now
oh yeah behalf at the moment I know
you've had a little rain anyway see your
question thank you for calling I guess
my question was to do with um the stones
the stones which would describe the
Exodus
for the priests you have on his
breastplate yeah he was meant to have 12
of them and then those things don't arm
are the ones which are lucifer is
described with but Lucifer is missing
three of them in Isaiah so I was
wondering um what's the meaning of those
three missing arm on Lucifer's
description yeah I think you're talking
about is it Ezekiel we're looking at
Ezekiel 28 is that where that is where
it says every precious stone was you're
covering yeah you look here yeah I'm
looking here for the right verse yeah
here it is verse 13 you are in eat in
the garden of God every precious stone
was your covering the Sardis the topaz
in the diamond the Braille the Onyx and
the Jasper the Sapphire the turquoise in
the Emerald with gold
yeah it's nine it's not 12 so it is not
the same as a high priest but as the
high priest you know his twelve stones
represented the twelve tribes of Israel
Lucifer before his fall was a
beautifully adorned - his vestments he
was the highest of the angels and yeah
don't know exactly what it looked like
but God's just saying that you know here
I I clothed you and you with great
beauty and he corrupted it he took it
upon himself right but that's
interesting about the stones many of
them are the same as the yeah the the
priest is 12 and Lucifer has mine so arm
the other three which she didn't have on
his description well I'll give you
something to think about I don't know if
I'm on the right track or not I'm just
guessing here but you know ten
that tribes technically nine of the
tribes of Israel because Joseph was one
tribe and nine of the tribes of Israel
and that would be ephraim and manasseh
it really count as one they were carried
away and destroyed and they never came
back they intermarried were the other
Assyrians and three of the tribes came
back and that was Raymond Levi and Judah
that means that technically nine were
displaced of the original sons of Jacob
so don't know if that means anything but
ETA does contribute he had to it thank
God thank you very much all right hey
thanks so much Kevin appreciate your
call and maybe we'll see you down under
have a good a alright next one of the we
have is woody listening from Georgia
woody welcome to the program
yeah thanks for calling your question
tonight yeah a pretty simple question in
Hebrews chapter 10 here is that this way
in into it and nested and a lot of babel
crustaceans and the phrases but a body
has spell prepared me and i'm having
trouble finding the reference to Bible
reference is that high scripture floated
instead I'm learning exactly who is Lao
it is the mini and so many bodies
missing the church body painted yeah
he's and it's your connections not real
clear woody so I think I understood the
question I'm gonna put you on mute for a
minute in Hebrews 10 five here Paul is
talking and pastor Ross chimed in I know
you do a whole series on Hebrews he says
when you came into the world you said
sacrifice and offering you did not
desire now Paul is quoting here from
Psalm 40 verse 6 where it says sow from
sacrifice and offering you did not
desire my ears you have opened and but
here in Hebrews it's a sacrifice and
offering you did not desire but a body
you have prepared for me
and you might be asking why is there a
difference what does that mean one of
the possible explanations for that is
the quote that we find gain Hebrews is
from the Greek translation of the Old
Testament to again the Septuagint which
apparently includes that phrase with
reference to a body thou is prepared for
me and of course biblically it's
accurate it's it's not mentioned
specifically in Psalms at least not in
the Hebrew but we do find it in the
Greek version of the Old Testament and
it refers to Christ he's the one that
came to this earth to cover himself
humanity right the the Septuagint was a
it was a Greek version of the Old
Testament and I think they called it
Septuagint because they had 70 scholars
working on it and because that dates
back I think even before the time of
Christ they had access maybe to some of
the Psalms of David or longer versions
of the Psalms of David and keep in mind
these are songs some people sing
different songs and there's additional
verses you hear about years later and
that you don't see in the typical
Protestant Bible so that could be but
the point of it is sacrifice and
offering you did not desire but a body
you've prepared for me Christ gave
himself as our sacrifice God had a body
the incarnation of Christ coming into
our world I hope that helps a little bit
woody we we thank you for your call and
you appreciate your checking in with us
next caller that we have is calling from
Houston Texas we have Briana listening
oh welcome to the program is that Briony
yes get real close to your phone can you
hear me much better yeah and your
questions right I'm sorry
hi so my question is taking from
ecclesiastics 9/5 and I was reading in
and I was looking at assess for the
living know that they shall die but the
dead know that anything and I was
wondering if that is true how do you
explain
body experiences alright and sometimes
they call them near-death experiences in
DES same thing someone supposedly they
die on an operating table or at a crash
scene and and you know they're declared
dead but then later they revive whether
it's through medical intervention or
they just take a breath and seem to riri
respirate they died in a drowning
accident they're able to bring the back
and they they see and hear all kinds of
amazing things if they're dead then how
do they know these things well in
virtually every case that I know of of a
near-death experience if that's the
point they're near dead they're not dead
so when a person is truly dead I've
never known anybody that had their head
cut off and come back and said you know
I had this experience is it's always you
know they kind of died on a operating
table but they're not really dead the
brain is not dead yet the hardest stop
beating they stopped breathing a lot of
people are resuscitated after that and
we know medically they weren't really
dead yet their brains were still very
much alive when your brain is robbed of
oxygen and it's hyper saturated with
carbon dioxide you can have all kinds of
hallucinations and you can actually
induce them by giving a person too much
carbon dioxide and so I think that a lot
of these hallucinations people have are
just that they're they're hallucinating
they're seeing bright lights and
narrowing vision and the funny thing
about these near-death experiences now
how do you see your name Brioni yeah
yeah the funny thing about these
experiences if a person has a Christian
background and they're in America in
America they say I went to heaven and I
saw Jesus or if they're Jewish they'll
say you know I saw Abraham if they're in
India and they have a near-death
experience they almost never see Jesus
they see Krishna or one of their gods if
they're in China they say yeah Buddha
appeared to me so virtually all their
near-death experiences seemed to be in
the context of what's
already in their head from their race
there they're rearing in their culture
and they have a spiritual experience
I don't know that God's really speaking
to him now there's nothing to prevent
Jesus from talking to a person in a
near-death experience because God can
speak to you through a dream and vision
whenever he wants and God might use a
near-death experience to send a message
to someone but that doesn't replace the
Bible so and they're all different you
know some people say I died on the
operating table and I saw a tunnel with
two doors and one was blue and one was
pink and I had to decide in
reincarnation if I'm coming back as a
boy or a girl and I mean it has nothing
to do with the Bible all kinds of
strange things that people dream so
they're not really dead they're they're
hallucinating generally because they're
near-death okay so now let me give you
Bible proof for that there are about 12
resurrections in the Bible
you get Lazarus G Riis's daughter
Eutychus Jesus resurrects the widow's
son widow of nain so there's about
twelve Elijah Elisha both resurrect
children about twelve resurrections in
the Bible of the people who were
resurrected guess how many of them
comment on what they saw when they were
dead zero none of them say anything
about what they experience when they're
dead because they were real
resurrections and they were really dead
they knew nothing so I'm going I'm gonna
stick with the Bible okay Livie know
they'll die the dead don't know anything
now if you die and you're saved you're
next conscious thought is a resurrection
a thousand years may go by but it won't
seem like but a few moments for you you
see what I'm saying okay yeah can we
send you a lesson on the subject it's
it'll be free it's called are the dead
really dead and it talks about some of
these verses and talks about near-death
experiences I think all you need to do
is just call and ask for that and we'll
be able to send it to anyone the number
to call is eight hundred eight thirty
five six seven four seven after the
study guide called are the dead really
dead again that number one more time our
free resource for
808 three five six seven four seven
Anthony's listening in New York
Rochester New York Anthony welcome to
Bible answers life I get evening pastors
taking my call yeah I judges chapter 4
verse 4 and Deborah a prophetess the
life of Lapidus she judged Israel at
that time so I questioned her I guess
kind of surrounded the Warrens world in
your home and in a Christian home
especially a married woman a woman has
children I you know we see that you know
Deborah was a process and also she was a
judge so she was doing things working
outside the home I heard it said by
somebody I know that it is actually a
sin or woman to work outside the home
and precious children especially I wish
you when she's married and so forth and
I can't find any biblical proof about
that but this was and when I brought
this risk of the show I said well
Deborah she wasn't really a judge she
was all properties but I just kind of
wanted to know how we should so we can
reconcile on the Bible what well very a
good question I appreciate the there
perceptiveness and what you're asking
first of all I don't think this verse is
saying that it's a sin for a woman to
work outside of the home if you read in
is it proverbs 31 it talks about the
perfect wife and she's one of the
busiest women I've ever met
I haven't met too many like that woman
he's our husband rise up and call her
blessed geez the perfect woman but no
actually and I know a guy who said his
wife was that woman but um so I I think
he Christians have to be very careful
about saying that's a sin for a woman to
work outside of the home and if she has
children especially you know once the
children start going back to school you
the woman sitting at home while they're
in school and she could be working
part-time there's I don't see anything
morally wrong with that when it talks
about and I think if Pastor Ross has
proverbs there's proverbs 31 and and
verse 21 is the one you're referring to
actually verse 28 talks about when her
husband rises up and calls ablaze but
the entire chapter talks about how
productive she is talks about her
weaving with her hands and then actually
selling this fine purple this lemon that
she has a line land ripe she'd mine she
seems like she's a real businesswoman
when you see it she wakes up early and
goes out and go shopping verse 16 says
she considers a field she buys it from
the Prophet she plants a vineyard so
she's pretty industrious yeah pretty
busy business savvy in her dealings may
be the principle that we see that they
we don't want to neglect this could it
be wrong or is it wrong for let's say a
mother who has children in the home that
are very dependent upon her to neglect
taking care of her children because she
wants to pursue a career well I think
you know there's definitely something
there but there are many woman who are
still very productive many involved in
ministry who don't neglect their
children maybe their kids are at school
during that time maybe the kids are even
grown or older absolutely she can be
involved in ministry and even in the
Lord's work is we have this case of
Debra and she was a judge she was a
prophetess she even was pretty brave in
leading an army to battle and they were
victorious yeah she I'm not sure that
she was leading the charge but she did
company away with him because he
wouldn't go without her yeah exactly
so yeah we appreciate that and now just
it's on a side note about the prophetess
part in the judge part where it says she
was a prophetess judging Israel at the
time that were judging means that she
was helping them resolve things with her
gift of prophecy it doesn't mean
necessarily that she was like a Supreme
Court judge where she was determining
you know some of the cases so sometimes
I think people have maybe built too much
out of that but thank you very much for
your question
you know we do have a book that we can
offer you a free copy of Anthony it's
called a wool
role in ministry a woman's role in
ministry and it does talk about you know
how biblical it's okay for women to be
productive and and again the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven it's free we'll
send the book to anyone who calls an ass
it's called the woman's role in ministry
we've got Craig listening in Michigan
Craig welcome to the program good
evening pastor Doug and Pastor Ross I
have a couple years ago I think it was I
was watching one your videos pastor Doug
and you were talking about I'm not sure
what the title was but the one of the
things you were talking about was gay
marriage and the legalization of gay
marriage and I remember you saying that
there was only one time in history where
gay marriage was actually legalized and
that was in the days of Noah as one
during a while since I've heard that
could you speak on that yeah no I think
you're referring to I'll just tell you a
little personal tidbit is people always
come up to me and they'll say pastor
Doug you said last week on TV and I
don't I know it's hard to believe I
don't watch my broadcast and sometimes
on TV the ministry is showing something
I did 10 years ago and the folks are
wondering why I suddenly look so young
and healthy and I saw I have no idea
what they're watching I do happen to
remember I think the sermon you're
talking about was something I preached
when California had their Proposition 8
where they was talking about gay
marriage and it's a sermon called a stay
a state of disgrace and I was talking
about how the state of California voted
against gay marriage for same-sex
marriage and it was just overturned by
one terney general later became governor
and in there I think I quote again I'm
going you're going back 10 years I think
I quote from oh it's a reference from
the Babylonian Talmud that said one of
the things I think in a paraphrasing
here in the radio studio that one of the
things that was especially offensive to
God before the flood was that they were
men were entering into marriage
contracts with men
and that the Babylonian Talmud comes
from I guess their Babylonian captivity
and that was I think the only reference
I had for that okay yeah I thought was
very interesting that that is you know
one of the signs are devolving as a
society was the legalization of that and
then when you brought up that was the
only other time in history was in the
days of Noah that really brings it home
as far as the depravity of our society
well yeah and then Christ said as it was
in the days of lot so will it be and
then yeah when the son of man comes
that's in Luke 17 I think in Matthew 24
maybe so yeah where I think we've
arrived it was a if I'm not mistaken
Ruth Graham that said either God is
gonna have to apologize the Sodom and
Gomorrah or we're in a lot of trouble
that's another loose translation but
loose quote hey thanks so much
appreciate your call Craig we've got
Teresa listening in Anchorage Alaska
Teresa welcome to the program hi hi
Teresa we got about two and a half
minutes can we do it okay
yes my question is about the rapture is
I don't know if it's happening during
the Second Coming or before the Second
Coming all right very good the rapture
and the word rapture means being caught
up it takes place
simultaneous with Christ's return and
this is 1st Thessalonians chapter 4 the
Lord Himself will descend from heaven
with a shout the voice of the Archangel
the trumpet of God and the dead in
Christ will rise then we who are alive
and remain will be caught up
that means rapture we are caught up to
meet them in the air so when the Lord
comes but you know we hear pastor Ross
and I and those Protestants did not use
to believe even the secret rapture we
believe we're going to be caught up but
the idea that life goes on for seven
more years after Christ's coming don't
believe the Bible teaches that you look
yes Jesus is coming as a thief
listen to what Peter said the day of the
Lord 2nd Peter chapter 3 the day of the
Lord will come as a thief in the night
in which the heavens pass away with a
great noise and the elements melt with
fervent heat and the earth and the
things in it are burned up
doesn't sound like life goes on seven
more years when Jesus comes as a thief
so and in Revelation chapter where is it
16 where it says behold I come as a
thief and let him keep his garments and
that's between the 6th and the 7th
plague
God is saying I come as a thief so how
can you say it's a secret when it's you
know just between the 6th and the 7th
come in 6th and 7th plagues we have a
book we're going to send you a free copy
Teresa and that is anything but secret
and the verse referring to is revelation
16:15 Grinner it is perfect thank you
we'll send you that free book pastor
Ross will tell you about it the book is
called anything but secret in the number
to receive it is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four four seven and
again you can ask for the book anything
but secret if you're outside of North
America and you like to read the book
you can do so by going to the amazing
facts website just amazing facts dot-com
or dot o-r-g and click on the free
library you'll see a tab at the top of
the page
and you'll be able to type in the book
called anything but secret and you can
read it for free right there online or
in North America call and we'll be happy
to send it to you thank you very much
listening friends and you know it
wouldn't be fair for us to take another
caller but I see Patrick and Nicole and
so osh and Bob and Nathan I'll hope
you'll give us another chance and right
jot down your question give us a call
next week
thank you for keeping amazing facts on
the air if you don't know who we are
just go to amazing facts dot o-r-g and
the meantime we'll look forward to
talking together with you again next
week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five does your heart burns for a better
purpose do you yearn to do more with
your faith do you desire to be a
powerful witness ablaze for Jesus Christ
where do you start make your first step
at eff go
the amazing facts center of evangelism
here at Avco I've learned so many things
in my spiritual growth has just
skyrocketed
Asko has distilled fifty years of
amazing facts evangelistic expertise
into a dynamic professional and
educational experience that transforms
the nervous Christian into a prepared
and bold witness Affco is really about
learning while doing it's a
one-of-a-kind experience for those who
are serious about entering gospel
ministry and those who simply want to
make an impact in their local churches
and communities go to ask org today and
explore this life-changing program
equiping soul-winners setting the world
ablaze for god
[Music]
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air
so the blessings you've received can be
shared with others to find out more
about becoming a ministry partner please
visit our website
[Music]
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at